china has just launched
a hypersonic missile that can be fitted
with a nuclear warhead and what this
means
in layman's terms as i understand them
i'm no rocket scientist myself
is that you've got some missiles they
can fly through the air
and then you've got some missiles that
can fly up and up and up higher so it's
a little easier to move and then it
comes back down right and you have
missile defense systems to deal with
these
but then you've got some missiles that
go
way way up really really high where they
can then
fly you know outside the intense pool of
earth's gravitation they can fly really
really far distances really really
quickly and then come right back down
and hit their target even if they're
targets on the other side of the world
and missile defense systems are not
particularly effective against this type
of warhead and china just tested one
they tested a drive-by you know
trial
nuclear
missile
and
it was quite effective
we are here
in the united states
are worried about germs
and germs that by the way china sent to
us and we are here in the west broadly
worried about the sun monster and trying
to shut down our
our way of life because of the sun
monster and we are here in the west
throwing parties for ourselves to
celebrate the fact that a man is the
first woman admiral even though he's
never been in the military a day in his
life and how wonderful this is and
creating
now
multiple months to celebrate people's
sexual desires
and
deluded gender identities
and we're just so happy about and we
just man we couldn't we couldn't pat
ourselves on the back any harder got my
i'm gonna have a bruise on my back from
how much i'm patting myself on the back
here in the west
meanwhile while we are twiddling our
thumbs and and worse our enemies are
testing out hypersonic missiles hey
white house hey jen saki what do you
think about
this development that our number one
enemy
is testing out these extraordinary
weapons that could pose a serious threat
to our interests and even to our nation
what are we supposed to do about that
gensake
you comment on reports that china tested
a nuclear-capable hypersonic missile
over the summer to the surprise of u.s
officials are they accurate and did you
raise concerns about china's nuclear
capability
uh well i know general uh the secretary
austin i should say was asked this
question this morning and addressed it
but i'm not going to comment on the
specific report i can say and would echo
what he said which is generally speaking
we've made clear are concerned about the
military capabilities that the prc
continues to pursue
and we have been consistent in our
approach with china we welcome stiff
competition but do we not we don't do
not want that competition to veer into
conflict and that is certainly what we
convey privately as well
we welcome stiff competition
you
your answer to our
greatest
geopolitical
adversary developing a weapon that we
can't quite beat at the moment
a weapon that could land a nuclear
warhead in the united states very very
very quickly your answer is
we welcome stiff competition
what
planet are you living on
this kind of talk it sounds like it's
just more of the same glib and flippant
talk that that we've become accustomed
to from gensake and to a degree i
suppose it is but it's deeper than that
it comes from the rot
of this liberal regime
that believes that people don't really
go to war all that much and that people
don't really have fundamentally opposing
interests and cultures but that we're
all we're all just trying to make a buck
look and once
once we get some more jobs and iphones
for people in afghanistan they're going
to stop warring against one another
that's what barack obama told us once we
open up a few more markets once we send
a few more movies over there to china
once we buy a few more sneakers from
their nike factories we're not going to
go to war we don't we don't look we're
all just trying to make a buck
it's just the the free marketplace of
ideas the free marketplace of
literal markets
we just we just welcome that stiff
competition i do not welcome nuclear
competition from our chief enemy okay i
don't at least i don't
i guess i view the world a little bit
differently these are not serious people
jen saki and joe biden and kamala harris
and pete bootage and all the rest of
them they are not serious people they
are living in a fantasy land biden in
particular has spent the last 30 years
cheering on the rise of china as
recently as what 10 years ago
he applauded the rise of china the
entrance of china into the
world trade organization the entrance of
china
really into the world marketplace oh
it's wonderful a rising tide lifts all
ships right well i don't know
looks like our ship is possibly going to
capsize if we don't stabilize it
no it's great it's wonderful it's we're
going to take six months paternity leave
during
during a cri it takes ten months why
would you come home you're doing that
joyful work
of staying at home with your baby so why
would you have to come in and
run our ship of state
why does joe biden doesn't need to
campaign he doesn't need to pay
attention really to anything at all
why why do we need to do any of it
uh jen saki doesn't need to give real
answers to the american we don't need to
do any of it we're all just pretending
and
we're being told that delusions are
compassionate and that there's nothing
more wonderful and and uh charitable
than
than pretending that it's not that that
national security threats are not a
threat or pretending that
hordes and hordes of migrants being
brought over by criminal cartels are
that's not a problem and enforcing our
laws is not a big deal
and
pretending that men are women that's
totally fine we're being told that's not
that's actually compassionate to live in
those lives well the consequence of
living in those lives is that your
civilization collapses okay the the
consequence of living in lies is that
people who are
more in touch with reality are going to
eat your lunch and that's what's going
on right now you want to hear about the
real supply chain crisis the real supply
chain crisis is that i've got a supply
of these videos but sometimes they don't
make it to their intended destination
that being you and it's because you got
to ring that bell you got to subscribe
even more importantly you got to go to
apple podcast spotify stitcher google
play wherever you get your podcast type
in the michael knowles show to do click
it subscribe maybe leave a five star
review and we will see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you